it's its 85th year anniversary
diplomatic Academy is a major
educational research center trains
qualified specialists in the Foreign
Relations covering a wide range of
relevant areas together with hungee
modes one of the major suppliers of
staff for domestic foreign policy
service Academy is a platform for used
for regular building expertise and
honing skills by both MFA in place and
Russian agencies and foreign diplomats
ministries to share his vision according
to the current agenda focused on Russian
priorities and respond to questions on
the 12th of April to take part in the
conference to establish the association
of foreign policy studies named after
gramatica this is made of members of
domestic a non-governmental academy
indication organizations representatives
and for an in-order foster dialogue
among experts between the member states
of CAS a UNSC Sto the future event is to
feature species of weapon that is
voluntary in public and business circles
as well as international relations
experts from the Russian Federation
Republic of Belarus the agenda includes
shoot and launch on plans which will be
reflected in the outcome documents of
the conference the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Russia Sergey Lavrov is to
see the prepared exhibition by the
Department of History and documentation
it is held on the occasion of our tenth
anniversary the birth of the outstanding
Soviet diplomat and statesman and three
Grammy Co on the same day on the 12th of
April the mention of the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of Russia involving the
heads of the Ministry of Foreign Affairs
there'll be a presentation
of the album Sirius invincible published
by the Russia Cuban Friendship Society
on the occasion of the 85th year of
birthday of the legal guardian and 1992
year anniversary of the of the birth of
Che Guevara these collections show the
milestones of these two outstanding
personalities of the 20th century of a
special interest is the Chronicle or
official context and unofficial meetings
of Gagarin and Che Guevara in Moscow and
Havana
it shows symbolic intersection between
fates of the pioneer of space and
lighting
late in American revolutionary this
event is to become another confirmation
of historically strong ties of
friendship conquers in between the
peoples of Russia and Cuba the
invitation to the presentation was sent
to the heads of diplomatic missions of
Latin American and Caribbean countries
to the members of the Russian society of
rusa Cuban friendship society
representatives of state institutions
cultural and academic culture and
academia
there'll be the exhibition of pictures
from two photo albums we also invite
representatives of Russian and foreign
mass media to take part in this event on
the 13th and 14th of April in this new
dolly passionate there'll be a new
meeting of Council on foreign defense
policy this is a long-time
non-government organization dealing with
foreign policy issues during the
discussion on global war evolution what
to expect the issues of the current
international context and practice of
Russian foreign policy will be addressed
in accordance with existing tradition
the assemblies to be attended by the
Minister of Foreign Affairs Sergei
Lavrov he is to address the participants
and he share his
assessments of the current international
context and will also cover the topical
priorities of Russian
diplomatic activity the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs appreciates constructive
cooperation with the council on foreign
and defence policy these ideas from the
least organisations in high demands in
our practical activities that are also
announcements of these of the next
events the Minister of the Foreign
Affairs of Russia Azerbaijan is to hold
15th of April and Moscow a meeting
dedicated to the Goron Karabakh affairs
it will also be attended by co-chairs of
a men's group of policy Russia yes and
France on the 16th of April Moscow is to
see the 15 sterilization Russian Arabic
operation forum attended by the Minister
of Foreign Affairs of the Russian
Federation Sergei Lavrov in accordance
with a format which was established in
December 2009 the event is to be
attended by the representatives of
ministers of the Arab League including
Iraq Sudan and Somalia and Tunisia as an
action share of Al summit and also
secretary-general of the Arab League
will also expect the coming of the heads
of the ministries of Foreign Affairs of
other Arab countries
there'll be an exchange of opinions on
the Middle East and North African
appears in relation to the points of
tension and responding to challenges
there will be exchange of opinions
regarding the regional international
issues including Palestine israelian
settlement the situation in Syria maybe
a Jelena complex
comprehensive normalization of the
Persian Gulf situation countering
terrorism extremism and building zone
and East free from mass destruction
weapons there will be a huge focus on
strengthening relations between Russia
and Arab countries in trade investment
culture and
humanitarians fears after the based on
the results of the forum there will be a
joint statement and also plan of actions
to implement principles and goals for
the Russian Arab cooperation in period
from 2019 2021 we hope that the future
event will foster joint approaches to
international regional issues and to
build multifaceted partnership of Russia
between the with our world the message
is to meet Minister of Foreign Affairs
of Russia in quality discuss further
cooperation and develop our tissue
between our countries as well as the
topical issues of a balcony balcony
countries as you know it's we have a
quite strong cooperation on the 17th of
January this year there was strong
incentive given to our cooperation the
presence of Serbia has twice visit
Russia the last year those took part in
festivities on the Victory Day and the
marshal of the immortal regiment
meetings irregular and we also like to
point out that there is a balanced
course to build mutually beneficial
cooperation with all involved in
countries including Russia interesting
countries the dynamic of trade
cooperation is positive in year 2018
that trade turnover
according to the Russian statistics
exceeded 2 billion US dollars which
exceeds the figure of 2017 traditionally
the focus is placed on cosmos situation
and as you know the Russian position
this regard remains firm and is based on
1244 secret cars
resolution on the 12 of on the 18th of
April in the framework of assisting the
Federation Council the Federation and it
is in order to promote and strengthen
cooperation with foreign countries and
business community the reception house
of the NFA of Russia is to hold the
presentation of a novgorod region is the
it is to feature the representatives of
the diplomatic corps crates in moscow
and also the federal and regional
authorities the business circles Russian
and foreign mass media the event intends
to demonstrate a cannon capabilities and
lessen potential of the region and also
to outline the plans of leadership of
the Federation to strengthen business
ties with foreign partners they'll be
presentation of different projects which
could may involve representatives of
business considered institutions of
foreign States the agenda includes
inputs by the Minister of Foreign
Affairs Sergey Lavrov and the government
of Novgorod region and the nikitin as
you know the international agenda is
quite flexible there are any changes to
the schedule of the myths of Foreign
Affairs that give a rope you will be
certainly informed and now we move to
the main part of our today's meeting the
global city issue in international
relations and I will try begin with it
with the escalation zone
Hayate creation continuing attacking the
positions of the Syrian
still military and seals dying here
remarkable was the shelling of Hama
hospital resulted in five people dead 15
injured on the same day about 500
terrorists made an accessible attempt to
break through the sections of Syrian
army in Latakia area in order to prevent
the further escalation this big relation
of the situation we jointly with the
Turkish party continued coordinating our
efforts to build a demilitarized zone
which is foreseen by course
in Sochi agreements station in a blip as
well as all the topical issues of Syrian
settlement were touched upon during the
Russian Turkish summit mosque on the 8th
of April there are still efforts to
resettle the camp who located really in
the unlawfully occupied by Americans own
Rubicon camp and over the last week the
Russian party has in coordination with
Syrian authorities organized the jointly
with the idlers of the local tribes to
remove from the camp about 1,500 people
from the camp they were given all the
necessary conditions in accordance with
humanitarian standards in order to
return to the places that they're
forming than presidents and in this
regards we also drew the beta attention
to the report by the Office of for the
Coordination mentoring Affairs it states
the delay in implementing obligations by
donors so ourself 3.3 billion u.s.
dollars only 180 million u.s. dollars
were raised due to the lack of financial
resources humanitarian problems near of
the United Nations in Syria implemented
with significant delays there are also
quite obvious illustrations of such
under financing for instance a
deplorable situation and in famous a
whole IDP camp and they expected major
gaps in the food pipeline you may recall
that this is under the control of Syrian
democratic forces and their American
curators the humanitarian catastrophe
unfolding there right in front of our
eyes are caused by significant
miscalculations by the us-led
anti-isis coalition during their
operations in the southeast of syria in
this regard would like to call upon the
international community to support the
Syrian
Jarek post-conflict restoration our
Western partners it's high time they
stopped stopped their political trade to
then in providing humanitarian
assistance to our Syrian to Syrians and
the issues of Syrian settlement will be
discussed during the 20 to the 12th
meeting on Syria in the asana forma to
be held in or assitant the incident will
take place in the end of April this year
you will be informed of their actual
dates additionally and in the context of
Syrian situation we have also paid
attention to quite interesting
statements published by the u.s. British
and the Canadian authorities in regard
to use of chemical authorities chemical
substances on the 4th of April and on
the 7th of April in the town of Duma in
thousand 17 and 18 but they referred to
a number of threats regarding the mosque
you may remember them 2018 the Western
troika attacked is the sovereign state
of Syria these crimes were committed
only on the grounds a politically
motivated decisions while bypassing the
UN Security Council resolutions and
violation of international law including
the Chemical Weapons Convention as far
as the town of Duma is concerned the
active aggression happened several hours
before the OPCW
experts arrived who based on the Amanda
20r survey with interview with the
victims and to take samples and based on
the analysis to identify where the
chemical weapons were employed or not
the based on the result
on the events in Duma and Han Shi Hyun I
would like to read trade the Russian
position we have whole grounds to
believe that the reports of OPCW mission
on these two incidents were in fact
adjusted to the made up political
intention of the same aggressors I would
like to raise another topic which and
we've been retracing it's for three
times in role over the last month I
believe what I'm talking about is a
topical issue specifically the support
from the Netherlands to share interested
groups of the so-called non-lethal
assistance the statements of the Dutch
authorities that Assad the media
supplied in 2013 thousand seventeen
including different equipment where
intended satellite telephones were
intended in exclusively to moderate
Syrian opposition if they fell into the
hands of terrorists only by mistake
during not only journalist
investigations but also by courts
resolution made based on hearings in
Rotterdam and this deal the Dutch who
would recognized her are Arsham as
tourists organization however recently
the prime minister of the Netherlands
claimed that it's among moderate
organizations and he also claimed that
he it it is it is not included in the EU
or UN terrorist organization list we
have often mentioned that Western
countries are often involved a
indifferent dubious projects for
instance providing
non-lethal assistance to in fact
terroristic organizations we are going
to follow up closely on justifications
of authorities to justify the actions
including the NFA of these states now
Libya we continue to receive the
information about the armed clashes near
the capital of Libya at least we receive
this information recently between the
Siraj army and the department's of
Libyan National Army commanded by
Haftarah there are cases of a bombing
including against the only functioning
airport in Tripoli according to various
information those conflicting party
losing people and equipment there are no
Russian citizens among the casualties
the Embassy of Russia is functioning
from the neighboring Tunis due to the
terrorist threat that is ongoing in the
country we still advise Russian citizens
to refrain from visiting Libya because
of terrorist threat if we speak about
political assessment and international
community over the last week repeatedly
asked the parties of conflict to stop
hostilities and to start negotiating the
escalation of tension became the issue
of discussion at the UN Security Council
in this condition
Russia is coherently indicate the lack
of other options to the settlement but
negotiating a dialogue one and the
necessity is not to use force and to
involve all the responsible military and
political parties to restore national
unity of the country and create national
institutions that will be capable of
effectively
okay was priority issues including
countering terrorism which is on the
first place and I remember pretty well
that several times ago or rather long
ago with Russian side and there its
former asked questions to Western
colleagues first of all the
representative self France about the in
supply of weapons to the territory of
Libya and we were said that everything
is going well we should not even there
is nothing to worry about and we supply
weapons to those who needed with
maintained democracy and so on and so
forth and today we see or what are the
results of the support of democracy by
the West and what happens was the
weapons on the territory of the state
that used to be as a state but now is
trying to restore the statehood knives
and we see this and they will receive
official assessments from the UN about
the number outrageous number of
violations in the country we would like
to hear those who used to say that the
supply of weapons is in support of
democratic processes and they are not
threatening to the world instability
those inside the country and outside in
the whole region and speaking about the
genesis of the situation I couldn't but
mention defect which and the
extraordinary statement made recently by
the minister of phone face in the United
Kingdom he agreed with the opponents
from Labour Party about the bad
consequences of an evasion of the
country in Iraq and Libya and he said
that the dissipation of London in what
was meant as an event to stabilize the
situation of carried out by the Libyans
themselves coordinated by the
United Nations didn't go in the cones
would be desirable scenario the success
has reached right after the events of
2011 were not supported by the and
necessary follow-up actions and this is
the end of our quotations so the
introduction of a no-fly area and the
targeted bombing including against the
critical infrastructure for civilians
and for the states in general now they
call it the participation in the events
of stabilizing activities and the
activities are probably meant the
interference into internal affairs of a
sovereign state open attempt of a turn
over and public lynching and making fun
of an national leaders body that the
leader that used to be received by those
who later wear shamelessly giving orders
and even to kill him speaking about the
desirable scenario again the rotation
from what our colleagues said they
probably met two men to turn Libya rich
in national and natural resources to in
the provider of hydrocarbons for the
Western countries with the government
that was recognized and democratic but
in fact it was a puppet government so as
usual something went wrong in the well
in the West and what we see at the
moment for example in case of Venezuela
is AB sort of different case but it
remains pretty well and the situation
and the drama that we saw in Libya the
attempts to reassure everyone in the
necessity of democratization and the
attempts to restore the internal policy
in the country to use all kinds of
all methods of pressure interference in
the internal efforts in the sovereign
state and so on and so forth and this
take on those whom they like the
sanctions against those whom they don't
like and today the world is facing in a
surprise what is going on in that state
and the question is it bad calculation
again but who shall be responsible in
this case the problem is that people who
were writing those scenarios for example
for Libya let's be frank they were no
good writers and British political
culture it is pretty common to hear the
apologists they do it very often
because but but they it doesn't mean
that they really feel it just
remembering that Gordon Brown was
apologizing for a resettlement of
British orphans and disadvantaged
children in colonias for decades and
then they apologized for slave-owning
past and today the British politicians
are apologizing pretty often let's
remember the situation in Iraq now the
turn of Libya and they were not
apologizing but at least they recognized
that it was a miscalculation and that
was the scenario went wrong how many
countries on our planet will be
suffering from the same scenario and
then the subsequent apologizing
taking into account the crisis caused by
illegal migration our British colleagues
tried to desperately search for ways to
escape from any types of claims but we
have told me that all those who were
writing scenarios for Libya the
politicians and experts and the
representatives of authorities and in
the country they they live good they are
having a good life but the by others who
paying their mistakes with their lives
and lives of their families a lot of
direct and indirect victims of those who
wrote these scenarios and in the
backdrop of protests in the state the
next information about Sudan will
receive the information that the
militaries occupied number of
governmental buildings and they were
number of representatives of the ruling
party detained the country I had drug
flight suspended in the report of hot
room central TV is not working they have
no internet
we heard the statements made quite
recently and in this regard I would like
to say that we hope that all of Sudanese
political forces and security forces
will act with greatest level of
responsibility to stabilize the
situation and to avoid further
escalation we call to cells to solve the
problem is by peaceful democratic means
based on a wide national dialogue and
taking into account the complications in
security area in Sudan Minister of
Foreign Affairs of Russia recommend
Russian citizens to need to refrain
visit from visiting this country the
evaluations we will give following the
developments in the country Venezuela
yesterday as you know in New York there
was a UN Security Council meeting at the
initiative of the United States they
discuss the issue of
humanitarian crisis we believe that we
still believe that is not the issue to
be discussed in such a format we are not
putting a blind eye on social and
economic and humanitarian situation and
win as well but we see no threat for
regional and especially international
stability and security
what is alarming is the repetition by
Washington the idea that all options are
on the table we would like to repeat
again that the potential the scenario of
the use of force if it was what
political establishment of the United
States Mint we considered harmful and it
has no prospects it is dangerous to
inflame the civil war and we call them
to refrain from such steps that
contradict international law I would
like to draw your attention draw the
attention of Western colleagues have a
look at what you have done in a whole
number of countries in the world and
have a look at the scenarios that you
try to implement and what were the
results we will continue everything we
can to make the scenarios that we see
implementing in a number of states that
I have mentioned to make to avoid
similar scenarios in Venezuela and we're
glad that not all the countries support
the use of force but the United States
still tried to promote this idea the
humanitarian situation in Venezuela is
still an important issue mr. plans I
made the statement and it was something
more close to agitation of a new leader
of one as well it was full of Nusa
threats of the use of sanctions and the
representatives of the United States as
well see the violate and
norms of international regional law the
rom open attacks against the diplomatic
representatives of the venezuelan
government the recognition of new
leaders the captures of this series of
property it all reminds rather abandoned
young operations than communication
between the diplomats the united states
recognizing so openly the new leaders
so-called
ambassadors of when is well official
representatives of the country in the
world they are guided by their own
experience over the last years we have
seen that the ambassador's of the united
states people who has now had nothing to
do with diplomacy and even to the work
of executive or other types of power in
the country they are just people whom
the authorities liked and they showed
being good from the financial point of
view so there is this type of practice
in the United States and it doesn't mean
that similar practice and reinforced by
the violation of international law may
be used to other countries they
destructive line to violate the system
of international law is represented by
Washington is a concept of kind of world
order based on rules and it is imposed
in many countries they try to promote
this concept in the regional and
international area and of course Spanish
call that one as well and representative
should be deprived of legitimacy and
that there is no way for alternative
a government in the country quite
recently we have seen other developments
of the situation and one of the cultural
organizations the America the
Organization of American States also
following the influence from the United
States decided to assign a person who
was suggested by the United States in
this organization as a representative of
one as well and we see that what is
going on is bad because we see that
double power is being established in the
country and it creates conditions for
internal contradiction in the country
instead of helping to resolve the
situation and to build bridges between
the parties but when the political sites
and political movements in the country
what we see that they do sort of the
contrary things they put the sides on
into different corners and then they do
everything possible to create conditions
where the conflict is impossible to
solve through political channels the
delegation of the United States of
America that initiated is shown the
status of official representatives of
the legal government of Venezuela
absolutely ignored the illegal comments
by the other states of the Organization
of American States for example the
definition of mandates are out of the
scope of the council the issues cannot
be solved by the majority and should be
discussed at the General Assembly of
this organization Organization of
American States but the permanent
council as decision contradicts the
documents and the charter of our this
organization and it undermines the
credibility of the organization but no
one cares about
these things when they have steaks that
are so high we call our partners in
Latin America and the Caribbean just to
sit and think about negative
consequences that can follow after this
crisis and what will be the consequences
for the work of the Organization of
American States and the questions who
are foreign partners what will happen if
American others will try to promote the
formula of recognizing the
self-proclaimed representative how
others would react who will be the next
after one is Wella and I would like to
remind about the collective recognition
of governments and their capacities such
term does not exist an international law
and I would like to remind as well that
it is trained to do it in 2019 but we
have to do it this is a sovereign rights
of a state the official representative
abroad can be assigned by the head of
state the representative of the
government means are on the first not
able to create conditions when other
states doubt in the credibility of the
official representative of the country
and will do everything that depends on
us to prevent such actions as for the
issue of humanitarian assistance to win
as well then the run no objective
reasons to impose this idea there are no
natural disasters or house problems in
the country at the academia is and we
will try to help the winners wallet to
let the unilateral sanctions that hit
first of all the civil and normal people
and this is probably the main idea of
the United States of America to do
everything they can so that all people
in Venezuela should suffer and basing on
these they would create
and establish their political vision
speaking about financial resources of
local and regional authorities the
legitimate is not discussed
just imagine the imposed by the United
States humanitarian assistance cost
chance millions of dollars and the cost
is much worse of what the country is
losing just do something for the country
to live better without imposing this
humanitarian assistance country needs to
receive medical assistance not medicines
and products and I would like to remind
again that if we use the package of
measures taken with respect to one as
well and if we apply the same to other
developed countries and in the West then
what we will see is a absolute collapse
of a state whether it is a US state or
these states in the region of North
America just apply the same package that
you use for Venezuela to another state
and the situation will be even worse
Washington use restrictions and threats
when using sanctions towards the
countries that try to cooperate with
official Caracas against for example
cuber cuber is suffering against
American blockade for over 50 years and
another example of United United States
and their treatment of how they
implement the decisions of the United
Nations is that they still continue the
blockade and
what is necessary is to stop fueling the
situation and imposing external ruling
from other states situation in Iran
directs the moments I would like to
touch upon we received a lot of messages
to comment on the situation the decision
of the United States to include the the
organizations in the number of terrorist
organizations the decision of the United
States to put the IRGC in the number
into the list of terrorist organizations
this is one of the another case of the
minute the same includes math logic
skills concerns bypassing us UN Security
Council resolutions on Retro unilateral
withdrawal Washington from Jesus jcpoa
to ensure peaceful way for tigrin
nuclear program and also the attempts to
force Iranian forces out of Syria where
they are invited by the lawful
government and we have repeatedly
mentioned that the u.s. course to
confront Iran is destructive and
short-sighted without involvement of
take around there'll be no street strong
regional security architecture or in the
Middle East or stability in Syria Iraq
and Afghanistan we have informed
previously the Russian Federation has
taken decision to provide to Iran who
finds itself due to difficult situation
more than 4000 material units including
tents and bedsheets and other important
items late nights on the 9th of April
with the cooperation of the Embassy of
Russia integrin the cargo was provided
with the assistance of the Russian
Romania center of humanitarian response
to the Iranian party and we again extend
our condolences and express our support
to the people of Islamic Republic of
Iran now about Israel and the United Way
of
Apryl Israel had preliminary elections
the election campaign was quite tense
although quite correct and democratic
and we just confirmed by the fact that
say 120 positions in Knesset of the 21st
Convention were claimed by 39 parties
the voters are quite active they there
were about sixty seven point nine
percent voted but the turnout was a
little lower than that which was four
years ago
analysts already given their predictions
specifically and there were messages
that the President of Israel will assign
the current prime minister to form the
government according to the existing
information he can expect that his
candidature is supported by parties
having 65 deputy mandates the leadership
of the sport is referred to as in Israel
as right and religious have already
mentioned they're going to support the
current head of the government
but these are analytical data I referred
to them because there were a lot of
questions to common and requests to
comment the actual results will be clear
after calculate 100% of ballots of the
state Netanyahu will be acting Prime
Minister until the new membership of the
government is announced Nikolas with
Israeli and laws that premier
Prime Minister candidate has six weeks
to consult with potential partners and
coalition so whoever is at the hand of
the cabinet we have to expect this to
happen not earlier than the end of May
early June and I'd like to emphasize
again that in the context of different
election processes elections are
internal affairs of any state in this
case Israel
and this is the case of the people of
Israel we assure that the friendly and
stable Russian israelian relations will
the maintains as one of the priorities
for the future government the next topic
as you aware it has been nine years
since near Smolensk on the 10th of April
2010 the Polish President Lech Kaczynski
with his spouse and accompanied person
as well as the crew perished during air
crash this tragedy was a deep shock to
our countries as is known Poland
continues its investigation by the
prosecutor's office and also especially
established expert subcommittee but in
in spite of the conclusions of
interstate aviation committee and the
Polish Commission for investigating the
accidents of the Civil Aviation and also
following the common sense reasoning
there are different irrational versions
of the crash including different
explosions or own boards of the
presidential aircraft and there are
different speculation since nations and
versions unfortunately what we see is
there is a continuous address or rather
claims or accusations even against
Russia due to allegedly unlawful
detainment of the elements of the
aircraft we deem it appropriate to
comment on the situation due to multiple
mention in mass media after the smallest
catastrophe at criminal proceedings were
initiated in Russia it was investigated
by the investigation committee of the
Russian Federation still underway the
Russian party within its efforts
submitted 42
a quest of legal assistance to the
Polish party and two of them are not yet
fulfilled Poland on its pot submits how
the materials concerning investigation
and investigation committee of the
Russian Federation has fulfilled 32
Polish requests of legal assistance and
another four are in the pipeline as far
as the remains of the aircraft are
concerned as you understand their
evidence items and accordance with
article 82 of the criminal proceedings
called the Russian Federation they must
I quote be kept with criminal case until
the sentence is in effect or until the
term of appealing against the ruling
that lapses or the ruling of of stopping
criminal proceedings is taken for this
reason the remains of the aircraft
cannot take can all be provided after
before the investigation in Russia's
over on the anniversary of this
deplorable event that caused great human
sorrow nine years ago and it was also an
unity factor for our people you may
recall the unparalleled level of
openness shown by our from our sides we
call upon Polish party to to cooperate
and the aftermath of this catastrophe
requires from us a professional honest
and deference delicate approach everyone
is interested in putting an . in this
case i would like to emphasize we have
completely open and talking about our
competent authorities as far as
cooperation with polish authorities is
concerned we have reiterated this point
all along
we have drew our attention to the fact
that the Japanese party continues voice
and its concerns in regards to the
coriolis condition cholesky district's
activities and now the day march of this
kind happened on the night of April
after mass media messages about placing
UAVs of the Armed Forces of the Russian
Federation in these areas we have
mentioned many times to talk here that
Sasha Marsh is unacceptable in fact
their interference in our internal
affairs regardless of the truth or the
nature of such messages news messages we
would like to remind that Russia is
lawfully entitled to host any events on
its territory including to intensifies
defensive capabilities we consider the
actions of Japanese authorities is
another confirmation of their
unwillingness to accept the results of
the Second World War which was signed by
the country in the instrument of
surrender were and when entering the
United Nations 1956 such an entity is
bordering on rev revenge revenge own
rewriting is far from the vector to
develop cooperation to develop trust and
create positive atmosphere in a
bilateral dialogue between Russian Japan
this kinds of factoring this kind of
dialogue must be used to address any
challenges and issues and the way of any
de Marsh or any protest especially
concerning such issues as I have
mentioned is a way leading nowhere there
were a lot of questions regarding the
situation with seto of sailboats in
sexual waters of Estonia the prohibition
to enter provision for this boat to
enter Estonian turtle waters which is by
the way a training
sailboat due to the fact that there are
candidates of the Kerch state marine
technological university from the we
called occupied Crimea we believe that's
an odd and friendly provocative step by
stony authorities we now need to
understand that the Crimea is an
integral part of the Russian Federation
this is determined and it is not subject
to discussion no matter who and where it
likes it does not like it either in
telling or anywhere else any attempts to
exacerbate bilateral relations are down
to estonian authorities we have also
paid attention to the statements of the
EU decision regarding the draft
regulations for these are free entry for
short term visits to the EU countries
and associated Schengen staged by UK
citizens after it leaves the EU you
probably understand the connotation is
the the fact is that this has also this
document has also included a number of
British island territories in the Indian
Ocean
he used seems to turn a blind eye to the
attempts of London to sabotage the
process that the colonizing Mauritius
which great which the UK from each of
the UK took an archipelago and expelled
the locals in order to build an American
military base we are talking about the
human rights rule of law but at the same
time the colonial state is accepted as a
part of the year for more than 40 years
we hope that the you will
although the norms of international role
rather than the world order based on
rules as was mentioned today with a note
of surprise we paid out issue to the
fact that the department of state of the
united states have announced a threat to
visit in russia the US authorities has
again demonstrated its behalf again
demonstrated they're in fact against any
conference between our nationals these
can be seen by the recommendation
published on the website of the
Department of State to the Americans to
exercise the increased caution while
visiting Russia and at best not to visit
our country at all in confirmation they
give references here surprising people
there so fnatic talking everyone the
hall worked out of taking part in World
Cup championship which took place last
year and Russia could not but surprise
we explained it to ourselves by some
ideological vital or even political
demands from people who believe in that
in Washington but counterintuitive as it
is the more Washington tries to talk
everyone else out of visiting Russia is
the more Americans actually visit our
country the same happened the world
Soccer World Cup they try to talk
everyone out of visiting Russia but the
number of Americans was exceeding
everyone else but the unfortunate did
not support their own team the same
absolute deviation happens here
in justification they not only mentioned
criminal criminals that they mean
country which is not only the case in
Russia but in in any other country of
the world let alone the United States
and also any any and also the fear of
prosecution by law-enforcement
authorities there are a lots of scary
stories about crash in Washington
created over the last years and the
significant portion of mass media from
America telling these fake stories and
the results so of a remarkable attempt
to stop the movements of Americans
including the visit of Crimea but in
fact I would like to draw your attention
to the fact that there are lots of
foreign nationals American prisons the
US authorities cannot give in clear
statistics maybe they can but they are
concealing the exact information despite
how request we'd have no precise
information often they would not even
mention the Russian party although they
are bound by a consular convention of
1964 to do so we repeatedly pointed out
to the Department of State that such
violations occur and we also doubtful
about the accusations of many Russians
and such a prejudiced attitude is shown
by for instance the detainment of Maria
Boonton Washington who was a student of
local university against the bed runs of
rusev obey hysteria in the United States
was detained only to have in Russian
passport without any real facts on
attributing to her an attempt to
interfere in the internal political
affairs of the United States
she was made to accept your guilt she
was threatened with serious sentence and
and they were also severe conditions
some of this information is confidential
I cannot announce it but we were shocked
by it they were she was let out of her
cell only for two hours during the night
Sam imagine it's just a person it was
not accused of not of of killing or
terrorism or any threat to life this
person was in fact a student of the
American University and acting as
community activist without conciliate
she was never provided with medical
assistance which is quite normal for the
US authorities we have mentioned many
times
concerning the booty nurse iteration I
will mention another story later and
this situation is very is very
illustrative in this regard what I'm
talking about is bagdana was Ebola so
American special forces are in fact
conducting min hunts on the Russian
nationals on the 3rd countries that
country territories there are regular
publications of of people who were
detained by Washington in different
parts of the world last year alone there
were 7 people arrested in this way you
may recall what happened to Victor boots
and custody near ischenko the first was
arrested by American agents in Thailand
and then under the pressure of Americans
the local authorities at to extradite
him the second was simply kidnapped from
Liberia and was severely beaten during
the detainment and they were both
sentenced to
25 and 20 years respectively in New York
and yes representatives have opened the
claim that it was due to their lack of
desire to accept their guilt
this criminal rate near criminal rating
at his states is something they should
drew draw draw their own attention to
unfortunately yes Russian nationals
often victims of such crime of such
crimes it's an everyday life there are
even killing serious situations on the
5th of June 2017 Maryland
seventeen-year-old
Artem zebra was killed anti Russian
campaign and he concerns not only people
who visit the United States temporarily
but those who have Russian rules the
especially those who have ties with
consular diplomatic institutions they
are often interviewed by FBI they are
surveyed their their correspondences was
produced as if here dealing with
opponents of a current regime who
threatened this regime and I would like
to draw the attention of Russian
nationals to hazards that exist for them
in the United States and including in
the third countries by imposed rather
cause by American special authorities
but it's sometimes received with irony
but we'd like to highlight this
information and Washington and spares no
effort in restricting our nationals from
visiting the United States by limiting
the number of visas issued in accordance
with US laws the maximum wait time is 10
months 300 days with these results and
personal visits
I canceled visits for business purposes
canceled it seems that the US
authorities are now attempting to stop
any visits from Russia at the United
States and now mmm also trying to warn
their citizens from visit before they
visit Russia we are on the other and are
very open to our American guests and we
are very open and the department's that
of state is always controversial to each
other I can't but speak about this case
in details because I not because I know
there's some illegal statements on the
website but because of the in the United
States but because I received the
messages and information from her mother
I read the materials and after that I
just feel if without pain and I would
like to draw attention to the violation
of the rights of the Russian citizen in
the United States
once again Maldonado superb and her
children of five hundred six years old
they were born in the marriage of Donna
was a Bella with an American citizen but
they are now separated and the children
live in Russia when after the separation
she got back to the United States who
got arrested there and she was accused
and kidnap kidnapping her own children
and for two years she's been detained in
one of the detention centers in Kansas
and she is threatened to be sentenced to
43 years of imprisonment 43 years
including they qualify her requirement
to her ex-husband to pay child support
and it has a legal reason it was
supported by the court and this claim
was qualified as extortion that she's
also said that she may be released he
her children living in Kaliningrad and
being cared for by the relatives brought
to the United States it is complicated
to imagine that we're speaking about
this our current century and in fact our
citizen in the American prison is taken
as a hostage so although she others she
spends her three-year years or she
drinks 43 years in prison or she brings
her children to the United States they
would like to take away how children and
the rights of the children are also
violated because they are away from
their mother and father does not support
them financially Russian embassy in
Washington carefully following the
situation was with Anna Ossipon where
they provide her the assistance and they
found russian-speaking lawyer for her
who is in contact with her relatives we
call to release the Russian citizen and
to get the mother back to the kids and
the case next situation about the Czech
Republic and the decision according to
which in March 2018 according to the
request of the United States the Russian
citizen coolin was extradited to the
United States and he was previously
arrested in Prague and it is a case
which is closely related to the previous
one we spoke about the political
motivation and political bias in
analyzing the case of nakulan and they
were Russian claims to extradite him to
Russia but the authorities just didn't
hear our reasonings and claims but what
they did at that time they just realized
now and the question now who will be
responsible and who will learn the
lessons from the story
and we received a question we'll put out
the comment on it the special department
in Serbia the authorities in Kosovo and
Albania spoke about the establishment of
an special department of quote that will
be in charge of military crimes
committed by the military leadership we
believe that this is a step that shows
the further discredit ation of mediatory
role of the United of the European Union
in the conflict and between Belgrade and
Pristina they seem to create this as a
separate structure and they for this
reason make these steps to make the
assault is to implement the authorities
taken by them in the dialogue was
Belgrade and the European Union focuses
on the transfer of competences in such a
sensitive sphere of justice Kosovo
judicial agencies prove their lack of
capabilities and bias received the
capacities and authority that was
initially fixed by the UN mi k and then
later delegated to EU rule of law
mission and we think that it doesn't
help to build trust between the between
the sides and it may even exacerbate
further the situation in the whole
region and the next lot of issues
related to the freedom of word the
situation around grill Wyszynski in
Ukraine what we see is the outrageous
situation with the law with lawlessness
and they were accusations 200 the Manske
in all the charges he's accusing our
brave and he is connecting all this with
his professional activity in earlier
this year he was his home was searched
and Vladimir Scott Cohen April 9 were
also certain he is incriminated with
articles written for university that he
wrote in 2014 and he is accused in
attacking against territory integrity of
a state it shows that the case of
kirillovitch rinsky was accused on a
trumped-up case and he's detained in
prison and it's absolutely clear that he
have no has no other options but to
extend the dates of investigation and to
involve his colleagues and to pressure
his lawyer it is clear that Kiev regime
that has chosen the way of repression
say against undesirable points of view
does not is not willing to stop from his
illegal activities and Kiev authorities
suggest strengthening their actions
against journalists using pressure by
security forces and persecutions as a
punitive measure and we believe this is
a completely unacceptable because in
international communities calmly
watching what's going on at the
violation of democratic and legal norms
and they see exemplary trials for
journalists and attacks against lawyers
and make law enforcement agencies a tool
of totalitarian repressions in the hand
of authorities we call for reaction from
specialized international agencies and
human rights organizations next issue
British police and operation on
arresting of Julian Assange we draw your
attention that it was carried out on the
diplomatic mission in Ecuador with the
agreement of the embassy and the way the
operation was performed in makes the
impression that is a gross violation of
human dignity of the person detained and
we have that his rights will be granted
to him and we saw the reaction from
professional journalists society from
NGOs and human rights organizations the
health story with a Assange is a issue
of not just a today's situation but the
persecutions again the creation of
inhuman conditions
it's the violations of the rights for
word and expression and we cannot quote
hide otherwise and the next topic I
would like to touch upon is the issue
within this whole topic of the work of
journalists and the freedom of word I
would like to focus on one issue that
have been touched upon recently it is
the problematics and even problem of
violation of rights of Russian
journalists in France over the last
year's Paris coherently and
systematically deny Russian journalists
in journalist from spudnick
of Russia today France RIA Novosti
journalist in provided in giving them
the accreditations to participate in the
events in the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs of France for over one year they
denied of access cards despite that all
the formalities are complied with and
pressed card is a thing that is
necessary to carry out the journalists
activities in the country over 70 cases
have been identified in of denials from
the side of French authorities to grant
journalists permissions to Russian
journalists and it is all orchestrated
by the authorities of the country the
editorial office of Sputnik is now
accessed to get the information from the
government the Russian citizens and
Sputnik cannot cross the borders even
within European Union we are always a
very critical when it comes to the
accusations of ours and today I would
like just to mention few facts chronicle
of violations of rights of Russian
journalists for 2018 10th January
Administrative presidential
administration then give the permission
of Russia today to be present on the
summit and the so the request was
submitted in due date but the theme of
the presidential administration didn't
explain the reasons On January 15th 2018
the tunnels have not been granted and
access to the yellow sea palace
even though they had the press card but
the sources said that the representative
the journalists from Russia are not
journalists and the torture of the
country
which is the main reason to grant them
the press card next cases 29 May 28 een
according to the instructions from the
government
our Russian journalists were denied
access because they as it was said
because they are Russian journalists
even though the access was agreed
beforehand by from the correspondent
from the BBC was also without press card
but he was granted access we noticed
that the world's information that
Sputnik cannot be named as an
information agency they say that Russian
agency is what they do is just
propaganda and what they do is just
colleges through a revelation of
trumped-up cases and what they do is
just lying to the public and they say
for example that in Catalonia Spanish is
learned as a foreign language end of
quotation but the official channel
didn't publish this information report
contains the information of 50
recommendations to the countries and the
civil society and private persons and
what is recommended not to grant
accreditation to Russia transporting
journalists to isolate foreign minister
of propaganda at first they have to be
called by names and then they should not
be granted accreditation and they should
not be invited for the conference's for
journalists and earned a quote and for
illustration the what I have just quoted
thought to be called by name of the
president
McCrone Russia today and spudnick say
that they are adjuncts on their
territory during the visit of President
of France to Russia of Paris 25:28 of a
January until the very last moment they
were not accepted to the press
conference only parts of those who came
from Moscow were allowed to visit the
press conference which is not true but
because other journalists who were on
the territory of the country also
submitted their requests and the open
the question is still open we have all
the information that confirms that there
were other requests from other
journalists and France the issue was on
result of the Minister of Foreign
Affairs of Russia stated he's not
attending conference where the Russian
journalists were not allowed on the 24th
of November 2018 the Russia de France
became victims of attacks and also
members of rap layer party France was
slightly injured reported to shooting
crews were suffered during the use of of
teargas in January 2009 here in France
for TV channel and I'm a field TV
program was that published on French
television and I would like to emphasize
the fact that this is the state TV
channel France for the broadcast was
until it not only the children in fact
but to public in general what they were
saying is that the Russian media lies
Russian president is distributing fake
news in Russia is the most
my country on the first of February 8:19
the the president France
McCrone accused a number of mass media
including Russia to France of
destabilizing national situation by for
instance buying mass social media
accounts and he qualified some mass
media as pro-kremlin and he also put
them on the same line as extremist
movements referred to as fascist fear in
France on 15th of February thousand 19 I
don't know what kind of that accounts
are they talking about we have no idea
we have officially submitted a request
to the French authorities and had no
response and the 15th of February 2009
in they had of a election team of macron
said that neither Russia today no
Sputnik will be accredited for the
election campaign I quote they are not
journalists but rather propaganda means
they should not be associated with mass
media as they never check the
information and they published 10 to 15
articles a day unquote can you give me
any any of these materials on the 27th
of February 2019 a presen newspaper has
officially published an authority of
representative of French authorities
again attacked Russian must me the
ambition to normal accusations of
interfering in the electoral process and
distributing taken using miss
information mr. grieve wall has again
raised the issue of fascist fear
in in response as a response to the
question whether we need to be afraid of
Russia interfering elections he has
equalized them to a fashion that shows
fear I quote it depends on what we call
intervention what we saw in 2017 was an
influence of social media was the
influence of flattery and Nash's fear
they are very close to spooning Russia
today mass media financed by Kremlin and
established mainly by the support of the
fascist fear in March this year the
information was received that a media
regulator of France seeks to stop
cooperation with the independent
French station radio station booting
France regulate so to speed up the
termination of agreement which was
intended for late appearing in on the
16th of March 2019 another Russian
correspondent the the corresponding
Russia - de France was injured on his
leg on the 19th of March the editor of
Russia - de France received letter with
threats and anonymous author said that
her death is just a matter of time like
unquote previously the area's office has
mentioned there were multiple letters
from a different person before he also
called the editor's office and demanded
that it is closed in the early April
they were it was information about the
oppression of human rights on the eve of
the Trianon start up a forum which will
be held within the framework 15 of the
Russian French forum to be held on the
15th of April I'm not talking about the
intergovernmental poor or in Turkey
event its bilateral format cooperation
and the department's of skolkovo asked
to distribute his press release he also
drew attention to the fact that French
organizers with reference to elisa
palace instructions and this is always
the case with any situation of this kind
over the last two years instructions of
elisa palace that's the reference from
journalists from press services of
parties executive authorities of france
we hear the same thing from
politologists experts from people who
once who want to be interviewed the
referring to the same thing instructions
of ecclesia tellus and again with
reference to the instructions or of the
illicit palace they have emphasized
intended ly is this little relevant that
the russia today is not to take part in
these bilateral event i'm talking about
an event that is co organized by the
russian federation
how can you prohibit us from taking part
in it that was indicated in a letter
sent to the embassy it follows from the
above that we have given multiple
warnings and this period is over another
period has begun and we call this period
a period of mirrored attitudes to the
french party in this field and now to
other topics on the 18th of 19th of
april the council of young diplomats big
party in the 50-ounce international
economic forum the 18th of april this
there will be a sanction diplomatic
diplomatic and it's sustainable
development what I'm going to do
tomorrow it's the title and the
constraint in called back off the chair
of young diplomat council is to talk
about the perception of Russia by young
diplomats after the events of
14 the automatic sections discussed
topical issues of more than financial
political economic relations and the
place of young generation of specialists
in Foreign Relations in promoting the
interest of our country the main one of
the main aspects will be development of
the Crimea as a full-fledged entity of
the Russian Federation and it's also
full-fledged economic financial ties
which are now being strengthened and we
mentioned that many times the discussion
will also cover a new concept
now all these of international relations
the so called horizontal deep linaria
diplomacy I'm sorry
and there will be bilateral cooperation
issues discussed between young diplomats
you can be invited and I would like now
to refer to questions from previous
briefing there was a question about the
citizen of Russia CD cough this question
was submitted by the Ukrainian mass
media we had a discussion of sorts in
this regards we were told or rather we
were asked if we are aware or not I
responded back then but I also promised
to give my attention to to today of
course we know that our Russian national
he has been imprisoned in Ukraine he has
serious issues with his health his name
is city cop and I would like to point it
out to Ukrainian authorities who also
indicated he he is in difficult
conditions in their own country but they
appealed to the Russian party the same
time and they mentioned that councilor
employees of Russia visit him provide
him with first need issues medical help
in December 2017 he was he included
together with other
Nationals in a list of exchange lists
for swapping and but before the swapping
procedure Kiev refused to swap their
nationals
and it was Kiev in fact proposed the
idea in December 2017 to do such a swap
Russian never rejected this proposal
[Music]
there was another issue in conclusion of
the topic there was a diplomatic they
sneaked 4019 published and we are
presenting it today it's available both
in the printed and electronic form it
includes speeches and interviews where
the Minister of Foreign Affairs Sergei
Lavrov you can have a look at it in
different formats and I'm ready to take
your questions if you have them please
examine from Armenian TV channel after
the meeting of Nicola pacinian and
guitar live in Vienna
they have emphasized the importance of
bilateral project and there were two
proposals in nagorno-karabakh first open
the airspace of nagorno-karabakh for
international flights and the second is
that saharsky water basin may be used by
both parties what is your take on this
proposal can it bring the parties closer
to each other
I think this initiative as any other
needs a due consideration of those
involved in the settlement of the
conflict then if if the involvement of
other countries as coaches is needed
then this question can also be raised I
believe that this question and other
questions can also be considered during
the forthcoming meeting in Moscow they
have announced today
will it be bilateral will be a
three-part tight
you mean with Lavrov it is planned that
bilateral communication can take place
before the the meeting itself yes please
your no information agency or an
information agency you have recently
mentioned that the United States
referred to here as a terroristic
organization and Iran believed that that
you can see the the Central Command
admitted States also the terroristic
organization I have a question is it
absurd that Iran believes the Central
Command is terras because they're
responsible for very serious crimes one
of them was the shooting of flight 655
and then in July 2018
methen more than about 100 people died
including children and the United States
never took the blame they never
apologized they consider that as a
threat there are many too many other
situations of that kind they also
shelled in Yemen I have a question will
it be possible to file the proceedings
to the International Court of Justice
you have several questions the first
question I have already touched upon
this topic whether this Iranian
structure recognizable Washington as a
terrorist organization is absurd I have
already mentioned this is one of the
elements in the US
approach to demonize Iran that's the
whole point we must be clear on that
there are there are pieces of a big
picture that Iran is is bad whatever we
can see that and there is something you
popping up every day from the United
States towards Iran but on the other
hand you cannot follow the daily logic
it's an overall logic so to speak of the
original identity of the US
administration to this country including
their authorities people culture values
you have also mentioned a question about
initiating proceedings with the
International Court of Justice I think
this question should be posed before the
rather brace before take around about
its reasonability and its scalability
and then you have mentioned many points
many places in the world and I have
mentioned by the way the short airplane
during my previous briefing you said and
I said that the United States and also a
number of Western country has multiple
crimes in relation to different
countries of the world and we have
covered this topic today in detail and
we have also mentioned during these
briefings and while responding these
questions that Nationals of these
countries are always entitled they are
always able to submit to initiate
proceedings with regards to any
developments on literature of Iran for
instance and now Western countries are
apologizing they are now admitting that
there were unlawful actions taking place
there was false information which was as
bait was was a basis of aggression the
actions were well thought but motivation
was wrong we're talking about the modern
history it is not yet forgotten at the
same time a number dozens of countries
involved in different reckless projects
admitted their their actions of their
governments were not always lawful now
every citizen is able to proceed with
with court I have committed on this
situation some two weeks ago an American
journalist who wanted to file a claim
due to the violation of your rights and
territory of Damascus and now imagine
hundreds of thousands of Syrians have
lost their homes and were many many
years of their life were actually
stricken out of their lives are now
filing proceedings filing claims against
their countries I think it's the right
question to raise not just about
apologizing it's about considering it a
terror attack when they apologize it's
something usual for him but when it is
considered a terrorist attack then it's
a different case it have consequences
but they still are not considering this
as a terrorist attack I have just
commented on it yes please next question
I have a question about Emmanuel macron
French president elections visit of
france by ukrainian candidates to
presidency zelanski and poroshenko
how could you comment on this initiative
and the provement of Russian
interference in of the interference of
Western countries in the election
campaign in Ukraine this is what we've
been speaking about for many years it
sounds a little bit absurd the ministers
of Foreign Affairs including of France
were personally participating in
protests on Maidan in the center of Kiev
Ukraine is a sovereign state but Q is
the capital of a sovereign state
Minister of Foreign Affairs of a
European state of the EU countries who
are personally participating in election
campaigns for a certain candidate and
the situation was extremely tense and it
was done on two occasions on the first
night on and in the second maintained
and now you're thinking about the
candidates were not - whether it is
interference in internal affairs or not
but you should understand that the
country to which your agency is
attributed to were trying to demolish
the sovereignty of Ukraine for many
years so we shouldn't start with the
election campaigning of 2019 but we
should start analyzing the effects a
decade from a decade ago and to study
not like it is usually done in the
Western media to stop on a certain
aspect and that they like but it should
be done thoroughly analyzing the whole
range of events over the last decades or
how they were financing supporting the
campaigns how they personally
participated in protests
and for over several months we've been
following the movement of Yellowjackets
have you seen the participation of
foreign ministers of other countries
from Arab countries or American states
who were among the demonstrates and
demonstrators and initiating them to
capture the Elysee Palace or if they
were recognized as a new president of
France we have not seen anything of this
kind but in case of Ukraine we saw a lot
of cases of their personal involvement
the special services were occupying the
whole floor in the governmental
buildings of Ukraine so this is what you
mentioned is not the thing we shall
start our analysis from we should have a
look at the things that happened long
ago and what caused the situation in
2019 in Ukraine and to pretend that it
has nothing in common and it was in a
different situation in different
historical circumstances is wrong
because at least in the media we cannot
put a blind eye on the history of
relationships of the European Union and
countries of the European Union with
Ukraine and we should be fair that to
have a look at other conflicts and we
have to recognize that the granion
sovereignty
was being breaking for many years by the
countries that should comply with
democratic principles but the statements
about the fact that this is not true
we all understand Purdue pretty well
when European Union leaders if we speak
about France were supporting the
candidates to presidency of the United
States of America during the production
campaign in 2016
how do you like that story have you
forgotten about this this was a an open
support by a land to help Hillary
Clinton and nobody asked questions
whether it was okay to support one
candidate or not I do remember that
awkwardness at that time that happened
at the time of submitting a
congratulation led to a candidate that
according to Paris opinion should have
been one-day elections but it didn't
happen so it's a question about the
standards that should be equalized
somehow I think that there are a lot of
institutions involved for example I will
see they have their specialized
departments that should be dealing with
such cases and Russia is calling I will
see and this organization within OSI to
develop standard the norms to be
followed by all countries not one
mission themselves itself decides
whether to go to these or that country
what are the measures to be applied what
we need is the mythology and only at
that time we can understand
well it is possible to meet with this or
that candidate or the representative of
this or that political party and we
would understand the attitude of
international agencies to such meetings
and for the moment what we see is that
everyone takes it understands them as
they want and as soon as we realize that
nobody is responding our ëcause to
organize this organization to develop
the norms we started to carry out with
the democratic processes within our
norms because there were no general
standards so it's a complicated issue
that requires a lot of time to answer
information agency run rule variability
no no you have mentioned the decision of
trying to introduce the Iranian
organization into the list of terrorist
organizations and from your statement I
don't understand and whether it is a
condemnation or what we do not accept
the demonization of Iran by the United
States and we repeatedly mentioned this
and all our briefing so this is part of
the concept and the approach of the
United States towards Iran everything is
pretty clear
is it a condemnation or you do not
approve it or you just state the fact I
just mentioned that meanwhile the
decision in itself changes the balance
in the world in general we many of us do
not understand the provocations made by
Trump
it is targeted at the relationships
between Russia and Iran because
following this logic mist of mr. Trump
towards I LGC then Russia reason is in a
very complicated situation
if Russia accepts this fact I'm sorry I
just
losing logic once again if Russia is not
stating clearly that this is an illegal
step it means just visit our briefings
more often and read the transcript
because we mentioned on many occasions
that Russia does not accept unilateral
actions by the United States and does
not accept this statement made by mr.
Trump following the logic of the United
States for five years
Russia is cooperating with the terrorist
organization for five years this is
something that Trump just said and Trump
declared out the military forces of Iran
terrorists and after this decision and
all borders and so they will not accept
Americans as their representatives do
you have a question one just a second if
you have do you have a question to me we
can discuss but this is my briefing and
I'm ready to take your question I had
seven or eight questions when you have
seven or eight questions it's an
interview and we have briefing just one
question
Turkey China Iraq and even Qatar
unequivocally condemned the decision
made by Trump since well friend Iran
in Syria have special relations and
special level of cooperation then of
course Iran expects that Russia will
make a specialized statement we do not
recognize the demonization policy
carried out by the United States
administration's against Iran with all
the components that arise from this
policy and this is our principled
position thank you so we just would like
to continue with the same question but
my question is very short
well this step of the United States
putting IRGC in the list of terrorist
organization on the status of the status
of Warrington Astana format that is
expected you mean the status of Iran of
course not have just mentioned that we
are preparing the meeting in Astana
format it is organizing the format that
was initially launched and I would like
to criticize you for formulating this
question in this way we support the
relationships with Iran as a sovereign
state with legal government and the
statements made by the United States
with respect to Iran and I have
mentioned the whole number of aspects
sanctions and joint plan of action on
nuclear program we do not accept them
and I have clearly stated that the
previous question was about being short
and expressing ourselves about this
issue just because we mentioned it all
the time we have there is no need just
to dwell upon this issue for a long time
we do it on regular basis and we
maintaining a principled position on
this case maybe I haven't finished my
question
maybe the statement made by the US
president is an attempt to question the
status of Iran I think that it is not
the last attempt not only that was Iran
but to other countries our attitude
towards Iran as a state we have clearly
stated and we have not changed after
this statement from the United States
yes please next question stomach of
Andrei Sakharov Japanese TV special
representative of the Russian of a
president on Afghanistan said that on
April 25 trilateral consultations will
take place with Russia China but his
friends in the consultation will take
place the deputy ministers level what
will be the questions on the agenda and
who will represent Russia at these talks
I will specify this and welcome to get
back to you
simile and fury international live
Channel you mentioned the issue of
Venezuela there was an extraordinary
meeting and the UN Security Council and
initiated by the United States and I
think it is not the last one how can we
solve the Venezuelan crisis by
diplomatic means or is it an attempt to
get I have read five pages about one is
well on this issue everything was
devoted to just this issue only by
political and diplomatic means this is
how we see the resolution of the crisis
we do not accept the military scenario
scenario when they will use force it is
not something new we're speaking about
our position according to our
understanding of the situation and
taking into account the history of the
region and analyzing the international
relations
for the country next question
Information Agency Eurasia daily on
April 19 there will be six years on
decrement of Kosova and last year before
the anniversary was celebrated was
marked that the agreement was not
implemented the agreement on creation of
municipalities and now it is not even
mentioned because there are other issues
on the agenda and shows of course of and
so on and in this regard is it possible
to agree with the evaluation that in
case of course of international
agreements exist just not to comply with
them I think that there is a
geopolitical aspect that was being meant
and it's not about complying or not
complying with the internet with
international norms but there was a an
objective or purpose to divide kosovo
and brussels routine union united states
were involved in the issue and they were
doing everything in this respect they
were collecting funds and since it was
not a law they were creating bases
related to the political support and I
think that it is just a problem which is
wider than just complying with norms of
Serbia it's about modeling of
geopolitical strategic situation in the
region that according to our opinion
course that they fail to implement their
obligations if we have a look at the
situation in Kosovo outside of the
framework or outside of the legal
framework if we just review the
situation on the ground so to say and if
we have a look at the real situation
then the plan failed there is no such
state as Kosovo and the purpose was not
even implemented in the factor good
afternoon is Nika casa the apartment
assembly of council of europe has voted
with majority that for the first time
since the beginning of crisis encouraged
the Russian Federation to resume its
presentation to resume its presence say
in the assembly and to they can't pay
for the membership in the organization
opposed only by present a fabric of
Ukraine klimkin we always support it for
by the support bilateral cooperation pay
money for something that you can watch
my youtube channel is something
extremely expensive a full-scale
membership of the Russian
representatives in this body means that
we also pay our our fees in accordance
with the format intended for all members
our absence means that we're not paying
any fees and we are compensate and I
have seen different assessments I have
even seen that they have agreed to as
much as encouraging or a rather calling
upon Russia to be present during the
meetings I have read that several times
that was an official statement by an
official representative we did not need
to be called upon the Russian
party has mentioned many times that it
supports efforts of this institution but
being present at meetings without voting
without being full-fledged member is
something we're against we're supporting
with the idea of being a full-fledged
member and indicate in this case we'll
pay our dues but I'm not saying anything
you were just three traits and what we
have already said but love from the
federal agency of Muse a couple of
references to the attainment of Juliana
central Russia Breen
his case before international
organizations and the Ministry of
Foreign Affairs of Ecuador has announced
that his citizenship is suspended what
is your take on that first question it's
the severing it's it's an internal
affair of any sovereign state in this
case Ecuador and the first question
regarding the first question this is of
course violation human rights and the
oppression of journalists and among the
most vivid illustrations we this case is
also in this case also is and we'll of
course approach international
organizations but we hope combat and
journalist organizations will voice
their concerns here because this is an
unprecedented case good afternoon
trend information agency a small
question about the Monday meeting
between the servers and representatives
and the MFA sergey lavrov what aspect of
Nagorny Karabakh issues will be
addressed the whole range of issues if
there are no questions here then please
here
similarly the chairman of the state duma
which is love for Loudoun has recently
mentioned that if Russia leaves
Marseille Russia will be inside and will
claim the return of fees for the last
three years how strong will is in the
initiative be I think you need to
address this question to up on Ontarians
thank you very much for your attention
we'll see you again and our next
briefing is to take place in Yalta we
have caused publish an announcement but
please be accredited for the relative
forum in advance thank you